in the midst of what's considered the
nation's worst public health crisis so
far in the 21st century one Ohio County
is dramatically reducing the number of
deaths related to opioid overdoses first
on CBS this morning a new report shows
overdose deaths plunged by 31% in
Hamilton County which includes
Cincinnati there was also a 42 percent
drop in emergency room visits health
officials are crediting a new program
that gives away the overdose reversal
drug narcan for free well Don Dahler
went to Hamilton County to see how it
all works
Don good morning hopefully this can be a
model for others yes there is reason for
optimism good morning 115 Americans die
every day from opioid overdoses we went
to the epicenter of the national opioid
overdose epidemic and spoke to people
who are facing the crisis head-on it's
just heartbreaking what what's going on
out there and it's got to stop it's an
awful thing for a mom to go through
Kathy Meade watched her daughter Amy
struggle with opioid addiction from age
14 to 30 every time my phone would ring
I would think is this a coroner's office
calling for me to come and identify her
body she even used while pregnant with
her daughter Chloe I finally decided
that the right thing to do and the best
thing for her was for me to sign away my
parental rights
Chloe was one of more than
two-and-a-half million children living
with grandparents because of a parent's
addiction it makes me feel sad because
that she was early around for my wife
and while she missed out on important
milestones it's hard for me to look at
photos of her which she was young
because I wasn't there when she took her
first steps I wasn't there when she
started school this area that's been
consistently for the last several years
one of the hardest hit areas Ohio had
more than 4,800 accidental drug overdose
deaths last year 444 of those were in
Hamilton County Tim Ingram is the
Hamilton County Public Health Commission
how much of a problem is opioid
addiction in this area it's a huge
problem so we started to think about how
are we going to get people keep people
alive until they're ready for treatment
the answer narcan an opioid reversal
drug as you can see in this body cam
footage nor can revives the patient
within seconds Jeany narcan
since last October the narcan
distribution collaborative has handed
out more than 37,000 narcan doses to the
public we got this idea what would
happen if we saturated the community
remove the costs use data to put narcan
out in as many hands as possible since
the program started opioid related
overdose deaths decreased by 31% and
emergency runs for overdoses dropped by
37% something we saw firsthand when we
embedded with a team of first responders
in Hamilton County is there such thing
as a typical night when it comes to
dealing with overdoses in this area it
kind of depends sometimes you know
sometimes we have a rush of them when
there's a new batch that comes in town
last year they saw at least eight
overdose calls a day this year it's
about five and the day we were there
zero doctor Shawn Ryan helped Institute
the narcan distribution collaborative
seventy-five percent of his patients
with severe opioid use disorder were
once revived with narcan it's potential
that almost none of those people would
have made it to treatment if they hadn't
had narcan available
narcan gave Amy a second chance at life
she has been sober for more than six
years and now helps others in recovery I
wonder you know why me why did I get to
go through all of that why did I get to
survive and I know that it's because I
have a message there is hope through
this if I had to go through that to get
to this I'd do it every day I just can't
tell you how proud that overdose saved
my life
yeah it instead of ending it it started
it narcan contains the medicine naloxone
which works by targeting the brain to
reverse and block the effects of opioids
so if there are no opioids in your
system if you're having an epileptic fit
or something like that
there are no bad side effects the narcan
is available at any pharmacy without a
prescription this is what it looks like
this is a single dose these are just
demonstration models by the way it's a
single dose aerosol goes into the nose
the amazing thing about this drug though
is that even if a person has stopped
breathing it will pass the membrane into
the brain the aerosol and can revive a
person incredible yeah well and you see
how it impacts families right for the
better and in this it gives them a
chance sometimes a second or third
chance to get treatment and to get off
this terrible drug it is a national
crisis I'm glad it's being addressed
thank you doctor